if you don't know this by now designing
is one of my favorite things in the
world
make your life as happy and bright and
cheerful
as it can be and little details can make
a huge difference
and we don't believe that you need to
break the bank
if you want to beautify a space so today
we're helping a viewer with her little
design dilemma with a few
upgrades each under 30 bucks take a look
hi drew my name is tasha i'm a single
mom with a 13 year old daughter living
here in new york city
and we need help with our kitchen
please help i love your designs
you're the best just please help me
here's my kitchen
my cabinet doors do not shut this is a
terrible diy
project that went really bad
i didn't even finish i am so uninspired
to click in here
i have no backsplash my cabinets are
being held together
shut with this spoon here i
really really need your help please
help perfect
okay please welcome tasha
hi hi tasha how are you today
i'm wonderful how are you i'm really
great i'm in my happy place i'm not
gonna lie
all right what bothers you most about
your kitchen
oh my goodness first of all i hate the
fact that i do not have a backsplash
that's why i tried my little diy project
with the
metallic paper which was a fail a
horrible fail
there's no cabinet space i can't prep
and chop food me and my daughter bumping
arms trying to prep and it's just
terrible i need help
okay well i am here and i am very
invested and i've worked with sarah
monahan who is my design partner in
crime
and uh we have really given
the love to this all right first of all
we found you a backsplash
that is a peel and stick tile and it
looks great you can almost not tell them
it even has grout lines and it's 29.99
so get that foil down oh my god
and this is this is what we need to do
all right now let's talk about your
cabinet beautiful
sarah and i felt like new hardware was
going to be crucial
so we found these polls and i got to
tell you like when i'm making things
weight
is really important for like chicness
and expensiveness
these are super heavy super gorgeous and
they're four bucks each
so okay the next thing is just amazing
add a little light because i am a light
junkie and
if you don't have the windows it's going
to be really hard although this white
is going to reflect light and
we found you these under lighting
strips that can reflect on the
backsplash
and create so much more light and
they're 20 bucks
all right now we're also going to create
some space with these beautiful
canisters they're easy to open i don't
want to even take the time to screw
open and close these are like really
easy just
lift you want it to be fast and
what i always do in my kitchen i mean
this is a much more ornate
um situation that i normally have by the
way these are fake flowers
and you can get them for 20 bucks and
just keep them there but have a little
something natural in the kitchen
leave some fruits and vegetables out and
tasha don't kill me but
we're gonna recondo that kitchen okay
first of all i also got you this is my
personal dish rack
that i actually pulled from my place
because
you've just got one of those dry mats
which are really great but this has
a little catch for the water and it's
white and it looks pretty
we have got to get to crisp in your
kitchen
fresh and i want you to when we hang up
because this is the 1950s apparently
when we hang up
i want you to go marie condo in your
kitchen
and really get rid of a lot of stuff i
want you to get
hardcore and ask yourself what do you
need what do you not
and i want you to get clean this
zen-ness is going to bring so much
joy to your life and i've seen
your kitchen and you have a lot of stuff
so i need you to get brutal on yourself
and
lastly when you don't have a ton of
counter space and you and your daughters
are bumping elbows
we found this really cool mechanism that
you can literally make like
basically a chopping block on
your existing stove so i love that
that's amazing these are just cutting
boards and these two
are completely affordable so this whole
thing
is like under a hundred dollars and
i know that's a lot of money but it's
really transformative you have bright
light
you have cleanliness you have more
workspace this is a
true kitchen makeover and you can do
things one at a time
but you got to get ruthless on your
stuff tasha oh
and last detail sarah and i made you
this it's a picture of you and your
daughter
and it has magnets on the back so you
can put it on the side of your fridge
because your fridge sticks out here
and you see a piece of it so i thought
putting nice
metallic frames or magnets on your
fridge will create a little strip of art
rather than
clutter oh thank you so much
also you know what you don't have to
spend anything because we're sending all
of this to you plus more
tasha so and a 500 gift card
to hiring a handyman to help you do all
of this
and get it done so you get in those
cabinets you start decluttering
you have a gentleman coming your way
with 500 bucks to spend and every single
detail in this kitchen
tasha thank you for participating in
this with me
thank you so much drew i love the thigh
dilemmas
thank you tasha
[Music]